let's talk about lying I'm against lying
and I know that that's a quaint
statement to make at this point but I
want to hear the truth from our
politicians even if it's not good but
not all lying is created equal lying
about I reduce the deficit when in
reality you reduce the rate at which the
deficit was growing okay I mean listen
these are lies
they're provable lies but it's very
different than the pandemic is under
control it'll go away soon no one will
die we will have few cases Donald Trump
cannot and will not stop lying about
coronavirus and this included and it
continued when he announced the national
emergency for coronavirus on Friday a
national emergency for something he said
two weeks ago was nothing and would be
going away no he announced it at a White
House press conference on Friday and one
of the things Donald Trump announced was
that Google is making a national
coronavirus testing website where you
can type in your symptoms follow a
flowchart process to be told do you need
a test and then be directed to the
closest testing location to go and get
tested for kovat 19 let's take a look at
what Donald Trump said and then we'll
look at what the truth is I want to
thank Google Google is helping to
develop a website it's going to be very
quickly done
unlike websites of the past to determine
whether a test is warranted and to
facilitate testing at a nearby
convenient location notice that Trump
even interrupted his lie there to say
that other websites weren't developed
quickly he was referring to
healthcare.gov the Obamacare website
again just obsessed with Barack Obama
even as we're in a national emergency
now the real problem is Google had no
idea what Trump was talking about they
had no idea Trump was going to announce
this Trump even said Google has 1,700
engineers devoted to this project it was
all a lie first of all Google's doing
nothing alphabet which owns Google has a
unit called verily verily is working on
a triage tool for coronavirus testing
meant to be for health care workers in
the Bay Area who may be exposed in the
process of working to treat coronavirus
Google immediately started getting a
flood of enquiries and questions when
Trump announced this they had to put out
a statement that included clarifying
quote a statement from verily we are
developing a tool to help triage
individuals for covent testing barelly
is in the early stages of development
planning to roll testing out in the Bay
Area with the hope of expanding more
broadly over time Trump can't stop lying
remember that in the oval office address
last week he said we're shutting down
all travel from Europe
turns out US citizens and US residents
can go back and forth wasn't true Trump
said the Europe shut down includes cargo
and trade it didn't but still rocked the
markets Trump said insurance companies
were waiving co-pays on coronavirus
treatment turns out it was only co-pays
on coronavirus testing the man cannot
stop lying it is life or death for many
people it appears that Donald Trump has
put not only Mike Pence in a position of
power in this entire fiasco
but also Jared Kushner who knows
absolutely nothing about infectious
disease or pandemics or public health or
outbreaks he just knows nothing about it
we're dealing with bad people who are
also incompetent and
in way over their heads how would you
expect garbage in garbage out how would
we expect to get anything but garbage
coming out when everything that is being
put in is garbage by people who don't
know what they're doing are in over
their heads and seem to care more about
optics and elections than actually
preventing death that's the bottom line
I want to give a quick shout-out to one
of our sponsors VIN Chara watches
they're giving my audience 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch maybe you don't
usually wear a watch and you've been
thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have check out VIN Charo it's an
American company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look amazing and they
look like something you'd spend a lot of
money on but ever even chair Oh watch
ranges from a hundred and fifty to three
hundred dollars I went on their website
and picked out the kairos in white and
silver really love the look the
combination of the white face and the
beige band really love this one they
also sent me the Kyros limited release
gold reserve set totally different style
this one would make a fantastic gift for
a couple people I can think of in my
family any time you see me wearing a
watch on the show I'm wearing a Vinci
row watch go through their collection I
know you'll find something you like and
you'll get 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch